[Applause]
ah
[Music]
but if they like it too much one day
being strange to see a child of 78
years already in that
[Music]
when there are for commands I always
I take the shirt from the controls and
put because they respect respect
in still
[Music]
i
sometimes it's a very difficult decision the
even think you can go to a place that
he does not know the world
we could lose your life
you want to help others but
you also want to protect people
who are under touching me during turns
[Music]
do not
we ask him to give us the blessing of
grant us to fulfill the mission that
we have embraced and that we do
voluntarily and with all the love for
to be able to fulfill with that the prayer of
command is something very cute and has a
great meaning for all those who
we are commands
[Music]